crammed into a private kitchen
politicians celebrate what they say is
clean water
a photo op meant to reassure residents
near East Palestine Ohio after this on
February 3rd this train carrying Vinyl
chloride derailed and caught fire
a toxic plume forced those nearby to
evacuate the chemical later released to
avoid a bigger explosion now the federal
government is taking over the cleanup
ordering the rail company to take
certain steps if the company fails to
complete any action ordered by EPA
the agency will immediately step in
conduct the work ourselves and then
Force Norfolk Southern to pay triple in
cost accordance to the powers granted by
my agency
in no way shape or form will Norfolk
Southern get off the hook for the mess
that they created state and federal
officials also toured a new mobile
Health Clinic many residents say they
have been complaining from the start
about headaches rashes and other medical
ailments that officials have so far said
are not related to the crash but some
say it is far too early to rule that out
they should be monitoring these people
they should be doing your analysis they
should be doing blood draws and our
concern has always been are they testing
for every chemical nobody has even
mentioned dioxide and how toxic dioxin
and how toxic that is nearly three weeks
later a new attempt to stem the
criticism and calm fears but some
residents say it's not working I I feel
like I'm looking on social media to find
my answers and there's a wide variety of
answers being given that are scaring me
yeah just being honest is scaring me
um and I don't really feel safe to have
my children here because I'm worried
about those health effects impacts that
could be felt for years to come long
after the debris is cleared and the
politicians have left Patty Calhoun Al
Jazeera